madame monsieur bonsoir algérie le
président chadli doit commencer dans
quelques instants son allocution
télévisée une trentaine de morts cet
après midi à bab el-oued
les usines renault paralysé l'une après
l'autre par le conflit du mans la régie
faire plus de 4000 voitures par jour
qui veut la peau de roger rabbit ronnie
wood sort de son chapeau une nouvelle
prouesse technique me film me dessin
animé qui a enthousiasmé les amériques
l'algérie est-elle au bord de la guerre
civile depuis quelques secondes le
président algérien
vous allez le voir s'adresse en direct à
la télévision à son peuple traumatisé et
endeuillé par six jours d'émeutes de ce
discours qui devrait commencer donc dans
quelques instants à peine de ce discours
dépendent
voilà qui commence maintenant je cache
un peu le président chadli notre ville
comme lieu de ce discours donc des
pentes probablement la survie politique
du président chadli est aussi la
capacité du régime lui-même à surmonter
cette crise sanglante
nous reviendrons donc sur le contenu du
discours d'ici une vingtaine de minutes
quand on en connaîtra les grandes lignes
mais tout de suite l'ambiance ce soir à
alger alger où les intégristes ont bravé
les forces de l'ordre en manifestant
devant le siège de la sûreté nationale à
bab el oued
il y aurait une trentaine de morts et
plusieurs dizaines de blessés sur place
jacques merli nous sommes sur le point
d'approuver la manifestation s'est
terminée dans le sang à 19 heures le
bilan elkann trinque à 30 morts et
plusieurs dizaines de blessés
il va certainement en dessous de la
réalité
nous étions nous mêmes dans cette
manifestation et nous avons pu assister
aux premiers affrontements se sont
produits à l'entrée de bab el-oued avant
la direction
dans la foule la manifestation de cet
après midi ne rassemblait plus seulement
des adolescents mais des hommes et même
des femmes prêts à défier un régime dans
lequel ils ne se reconnaissent plus
chadli bendjedid militaire de carrière
rond ce soir le silence qu'ils
observaient la présidence depuis le
début des troubles mais triste il encore
l'appareil militaire et administratif
qui l'a installé au pouvoir en 79 à la
mort de boumédiène et qui a enlisé le
pays dans une crise économique profonde
philippe kasse ou dans les premières
heures de l'émeute le président chadli
s'en remettait à l'armée incontournable
il en est le chef et c'est elle qui a
permis son accession à la présidence
d'un côté le général belhouchet de
l'autre le général nezzar ils reçoivent
et accepte l'ordre de mater les
émeutiers le président chadli ancien
colonel utilise la constitution qui
donne à la troupe le pouvoir de ramener
le calme
autre composante de la société
algérienne le fln le parti unique fort
de ses sept années de guerre
d'indépendance et de son million de
martyrs
la dernière réunion n'inverse pas la
tendance
il faut que force reste à la loi cette
loi est représentée essentiellement par
les militaires
chadli le modéré prix entre le fln le
parti et les militaires fait donner les
mitrailleuses
le projet audacieux d'économie planifiée
a depuis longtemps fait la preuve de sa
faillite le pétrole qui a culminé à 35
dollars le baril s'effondre à moins de
l'apport en devises représenté par l'or
noir avoisine les 98%
les recettes divisées par deux
entraînent des coupes sombres dans les
importations de matières premières
notamment le blé l'élément de base les
prix flambent il faut presque une
semaine de travail pour acheter un kilo
de viande les sociétés nationalisées
souvent suréquipés sont sous utilisées
et leurs services ne sont crédités par
le gouvernement qu'après des délais
considérables
les prix montent et la planche à billets
tourne le président chen livre donc sa
marge de manoeuvre
extraits
moment réduite entre les socialistes
dogmatique qui représente les durs du
fln partisan d'une économie dirigée de
l'armée sans laquelle rien n'est
possible de la réalité d'une caisse
pratiquement vide
sans oublier les quelque 200 morts
ramassés sur les trottoirs des
principales villes du pays
le discours que le président enchaîne me
prononce donc en ce moment même et suivi
avec attention bien sûr dans la
nombreuse communauté algérienne en
france
comment les jeunes beurs qui se sentent
si proches de leurs frères algériens
réagissent tine c'est la question que je
poserai tout à l'heure en direct aux
animateurs de radio beur que vous voyez
et qui écoute donc en ce moment le
discours en fin d'après midi à paris des
algériens à manifester au trocadéro leur
solidarité avec les émeutiers
un millier de personnes environ ont
demandé l'arrêt des massacres en algérie
ils ont tenté d'atteindre l'ambassade
ils ont été bloqués par les forces de
l'ordre
la semaine commence en france sous le
signe des conflits sociaux d'abord à la
régie renault où les revendications de
250 personnes d'un atelier du mans
paralyse presque toutes les usines de
montage jusqu'en belgique
christophe martet depuis dix jours
michel pelé est en grève comme 250 de
ses collègues de l'atelier 81 où l'on
fabrique les points arrière des
véhicules renault
motif une prime de 700 francs distribués
à 25 d'entre eux pour effort
exceptionnel pour les grévistes
une prime à la tête du client absolument
la tête clients puisque
même genre qui travaille sur la chaîne
surtout ne pas lui dire les gens qui
travaillent dans le même atelier dans le
même sexuels ont eu et d'autre part le
dot pas au bail paraît qu'on a la
sélectionner les meilleurs au palais
toulouse est la sélection des meilleurs
dans le sens où je crois que les plus
compétitifs s'ils étaient présents sur
votre voiture
cette grève met en lumière la fragilité
du système renault basé depuis peu sur
l'absence de stocks 250 grévistes ont
réussi en quelques jours a bloqué la
quasi totalité de la production de
voitures et plus de 20000 personnes sans
ce soir en chômage technique une logique
pourtant rejeté par les syndicats
la liberté du travail respectée puisque
dans ce bâtiment on a des gens en grève
il ya également des gens qui travaillent
et jusqu'à présent ça je pense bien et
on souhaite que ça continue
mais c'est quand même l'ensemble du
groupe qui est qui est menacée par cette
grève
alors bon bien sûr l'ensemble du groupe
et les régimes qui se trouve arrêté
actuellement mais encore une fois
c'était paul l'optique des gens du gg
c'est pas de bloquer les autres usines
du groupe
c'est de faire aboutir leurs
revendications mais l'art et la red et
des autres usines c'est une conséquence
de l'action c'est pas une volonté selon
la direction qui a refusé la présence
des caméras il n'est pas question de
revenir sur les attributions de primes
pour l'instant toutes les discussions se
sont soldées par un échec ou même moment
la régie annonce qu'elle perd au moins
4000 véhicules chaque jour et la grève
pourrait durer jusqu'à jeudi jour de la
grande négociation salariale pour
l'ensemble du groupe
autre conflit qui dure et se durcit
celui des infirmières
les négociations ont repris cet après
midi entre le cabinet du ministre de la
santé et les syndicats
la coordination qui représente la base
active du mouvement devrait être reçu à
son tour ce soir du gouvernement devrait
faire de nouvelles propositions
la grève en tout cas était largement
suivie aujourd'hui encore à paris - en
province un autre mouvement de
revendications à paris a perturbé
aujourd'hui le trafic du rer surtout sur
la ligne à
le président mitterrand a commenté
aujourd'hui ce climat social qui
s'assombrit accompagné du premier
ministre il inaugurait dans les yvelines
une maison de retraite à l'occasion de
la semaine nationale des personnes âgées
jean-michel mercurol
un peu de paix un peu de joie mais plus
de vie un objectif que s'est assigné la
maison de retraite de magnanville dans
les yvelines
l'idée aujourd'hui par françois
mitterrand maison ouverte sur
l'extérieur où l'on convient les plus
jeunes à venir communiquer avec leurs
anciens exemple de solidarité entre
générations une occasion pour le chef de
l'état d'engager le gouvernement dans un
programme de transformation des hospices
une occasion aussi de réclamer la
patience devant les protestations
sociales qui s'élèvent ici ou là la
protestation ne vient pas de nulle part
mais la responsabilité d'un gouvernement
dans lequel je peux le dire vous devez
avoir confiance
c'est d'apporter une réponse une
solution à ces problèmes il ne
commencera pas l'année prochaine
il a déjà commencé mais il lui faut
quelques temps quelques années pour
arriver au terme de ces efforts sans
quoi nous détruirons tous les équilibres
de la france et personne au bout du
compte ne profitera de ce qui aura été
accompli dans de mauvaises conditions
françois mitterrand a conclu sa visite
par un vibrant plaidoyer pour la
sécurité sociale
dénonçant au passage les campagnes de
catastrophisme visant à faire douter les
français le front social ligne d'angle
tous côtés puisqu'il ya aussi des
menaces de grève dans l'enseignement
secondaire et universitaire alors
qu'elle peut-être la méthode d'un
gouvernement condamné par ailleurs à
poursuivre une politique de rigueur de
président de la république vient de le
rappeler
j'invite mes côtés première chose on
assure à l'hôtel matignon n'être pas
surpris six années d'austérité salariale
la volonté des fonctionnaires d'avoir
leur part de gâteau de l'amélioration
générale plus un changement de majorité
le cocktail est explosif il n'empêche
qu'après les gardiens de prison les
infirmières avant peut-être les
enseignants les douaniers on redoute une
série de réactions en chaîne d'autant
plus incontrôlable que les syndicats
sont soit hors jeu soit comme la cgt
porté à la surenchère et l'impression
qu'a parfois donné le gouvernement de
naviguer à vue
n'arrange rien pour autant au ministère
des finances comme chez le premier
ministre on joue
ce sport qui n'est pas question de
lâcher sur les salaires et d'abandonner
la rigueur quand le commerce extérieur
et le chômage s'aggrave
on se dit même prêt à affronter une
certaine impopularité
plutôt que de compromettre l'avenir
l'idée c'est d'éviter si possible à
monter au créneau toujours dangereuse du
premier ministre mais d'utiliser sa
méthode en désamorçant les dossiers un
par un ouvrir des négociations sur
l'organisation du travail les plantes
carrière la formation et quand une
remise à niveau des statuts et des
salaires s'impose chez les infirmières
par exemple de l'étaler sur plusieurs
années bref gérer l'impatience en
évitant l'exaspération
comme lors de la grande grève des
cheminots de l'hiver 86 tout cela
réclamera beaucoup de doigté dans la
fonction publique en tout cas les
négociations salariales doivent
reprendre vendredi prochain un sondage
qui prouve que l'action économique du
gouvernement est apprécié par les chefs
d'entreprise 44% d'entre eux d'après ce
sondage sofres que publiera demain le
figaro approuvent la politique rocard et
45% estiment même qu'elle est efficace
pour éviter les dérapages de salaire
dans la fonction publique
nouvelle agitation boursière aujourd'hui
autour du groupe bouygues flaction a
augmenté de plus de 8%
francis bouygues devrait annoncer demain
qu'il abandonne la présidence de tf1 au
profit de patrick le lay en revanche il
garderait les rênes de son groupe
y at il eu un ou plusieurs coups de feu
s'agit-il de balles perdues le fait est
que malika 14 ans a été tué samedi soir
à noisy-le-sec et qu'un gardien de la
paix interpellé hier a été entendu
aujourd'hui par l'inspection générale
des services il a tenté de se suicider
tout à l'heure en garde à vue l'enquète
de michel mompontet cité de la
renardière noisy-le-grand samedi 20
heures dans le hall de cet immeuble pour
une raison inconnue une dispute éclate
entre une femme et des jeunes maghrébins
injures racistes première gifle
la femme promet alors aux adolescents de
revenir mais avec des hommes
les vrais un quart d'heure plus tard
c'est chose faite mais ces hommes des
policiers en civil hors service débarque
dans la cité ardoise au point premières
balles tirées en l'air
huit étages plus haut malika 13 ans
s'effondre mortellement touché à la tête
elle regardait par la fenêtre comme tout
le monde les incidents de la rue mais
selon les habitants de la cité c'est
étrange policiers ne s'entraîne pas là
qu'il a tiré en l'air a touché malinda
la deuxième fois c'était chez moi c'est
sûr la troisième qu'il a tiré par terre
c'est le fossé en plus il a couru de la
bad à cause jusqu'ici avec le revolver
sur des mecs qui sont selon ces mêmes
témoins au commissariat les choses ne
semblent pas s'arranger bien au
contraire et nous sortait le journal le
journal minute et j'ai regardé ce qui se
passe en algérie retourner et non 10 m
il ya une petite fille qui est mort la
police des polices à ce soir interpellé
un gardien de la paix accident bavure ou
ratonnades c'est ce que l'enquêté
tentera de déterminer
au chapitre politique ce soir d'abord
une exclusion
yann piat député du var l'unique
représentante du front national à
l'assemblée faisait preuve semble-t-il
de trop d'indépendance aux yeux de jean
marie le pen et de ses amis elle ne fait
donc plus partie de leur mouvement ronan
site car c'était au mois de juin dernier
yann piat pouvait sourire des 33 députés
du front national elle était la seule à
retrouver son fauteuil un front national
avec lequel elle a pourtant rapidement
pris ses distances choqué par le
calembour sur durafour crématoire de
jean-marie le pen
rejetant la consigne d'abstention au
second tour des cantonales
la députée du var se déclarait la
semaine dernière favorable au projet de
revenu minimum d'insertion
la goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
sur la question du revenu minimum
d'insertion
après une position tout à fait contraire
à celle du mouvement sur la préférence
nationale aux français en condamnant en
quelque sorte la doctrine du front
national après françois bachelot après
parce qu'elle a un reggae yann piat et
la troisième exclu du front national en
un mois changement de méthode les
contestataires s'exprime pour eux c'est
la stratégie du mouvement qui est en
cause je souhaitais pour le front
national
une autre ouverture une autre dimension
et je crois que depuis quelque temps
nous apercevons au contraire qu il
durcit le ton et il réduit son message
et je ne partageais pas du concept cette
stratégie yann bien qu'ils entrent
résolument dissidence elle votera oui au
référendum sur la nouvelle calédonie
présentera sa liste à hyères pour les
élections municipales
le divorce est consommé un autre rallye
mort au référendum caledonia celui de
jean-françois pensait sénateurs idf et
président du conseil général de
lot-et-garonne qui annonce son intention
de voter oui en citoyen responsable at
il dit la réponse à faire ce prochain
référendum était au coeur de la
rencontre au sommet rpr udf aujourd'hui
les positions officielles ne sont pas
encore annoncés mais les réserves sont
clairement exprimés
olivier lerner squelettiques la
délégation udf à la madelin se présente
seul françois léotard a envoyé un mot
d'excusé en rangs serrés en apparence
jacques chirac rejoint tranquillement le
8ème bureau
valéry giscard d'estaing à temps
les deux délégations se font face tous
les présents prendront la parole
pas un mot sur les absents giscard n'a
pas fait l'unanimité autour de lui
le cds est favorable oui sans réserve le
parti républicain et pour un oui
critique et conditionnelle jacques
chirac est confronté au même type de
problème pressés à sa droite par les
ultras qui préconise le nom est poussé à
sa gauche par les rénovateurs pour qui
le oui s'impose deux heures de
discussions n'ont pas suffi à
l'opposition pour se retrouver quand un
seul homme giscard et jacques chirac
resteront muets
alain lamassoure et alain juppé se sont
donc sacrifié pour tenter en commun
d'expliquer leur position commune y a
pas de différence entre le rpr et l'udf
et c'est ça qui est essentiel beaucoup
plus que le fait de répondre un
référendum qui est en toute hypothèse on
le voit chaque jour davantage une
opération politique monté par monsieur
mitterrand et pardessus rocard
totalement inutile du point de vue de la
question qui est réellement posé qui est
de savoir ce que deviendra demain la
nouvelle calédonie est d'accord pour
dire que des mêmes analystes aboutir à
des résultats différents
tout a été dit à lire entre les lignes
le rpr devrait s'abstenir et et l'idf
penche toujours pour le uss et lecture
du socialiste philippe madrelle à la
présidence du conseil général de gironde
aujourd'hui avec une majorité de trois
voix de plus que le total des sièges de
bourges votre situation est difficile
mais elle n'est pas désespérée
tel est le message qu'ont jean paul 2
conscient des difficultés économiques de
la région a adressé aujourd'hui aux
lorrains le souverain pontife était à
metz ce matin à nancy cet après-midi
jean-claude d'arrigo ils ont été nos
voeux les lorrains à venir aujourd'hui
accueillir le pape jean paul ii
forces de sécurité plus discrète
encadrement policier moins contraignant
metz et nancy ont répondu présent à
l'invitation de leurs évêques à ces
chrétiens rassemblés venu avec tous les
problèmes humains et sociaux de leur
région chômage difficultés d'insertion
le pape a tenu un discours ferme de
retour à l'identité chrétienne aux
membres du synode de nancy jean paul ii
a donné une véritable leçon de
discipline chrétienne la vérité de dieu
ne se détermine pas sur les résultats
d'un vote d'un sondage ou d'une
consultation démocratique at il dit elle
se cherche dans la foi et dans la prière
journée essentiellement spirituel donc
que cette deuxième étape du pape dans
l'est retour ce soir à strasbourg demain
jean paul ii visitera le mont
sainte-odile le sanctuaire alsaciens qui
reçoit près d'un million de pèlerins
chaque année puis ce sera la drees au
parlement européen
il se rendra ensuite dans le haut rhin à
mulhouse
et c'est de là qu'il s'envolera demain
salué par le premier ministre michel
rocard
c'est décidé et les dates cette fois
sont fixés le président mitterrand se
rendra en union soviétique à la fin
novembre pour rencontrer mikhaïl
gorbatchev et assister au lancement du
second vol spatial franco soviétique
l'annoncé en a été faite à l'arrivée en
france pour une visite officielle de
trois jours du ministre soviétique des
affaires étrangères georges bordeaux
messieurs mitterrand et gorbatchev ne
s'étaient plus rencontrés depuis deux
ans ce retard va être rattrapé
on en a eu confirmation après la visite
que monsieur chez vernazza rendu cet
après midi au président de la république
le ministre soviétique a indiqué qu'il y
aura deux rencontres les 25 et 26
novembre monsieur mitterrand verra
monsieur gorbatchev à moscou au cours
d'un voyage qui le mènera aussi à
baïkonour pour le départ du cosmonaute
français jean loup chrétien et au
printemps 89 monsieur gorbatchev se
rendra à son tour à paris donc les
sommets franco soviétique reprennent des
armements conventionnels armes chimiques
europe intégrée de 1993
messieurs mitterrand gorbatchev auront
d'évidence beaucoup pas dire au cours de
ces deux rendez vous successifs nouvelle
manifestation aujourd'hui au monténégro
tension à belgrade au lendemain de
l'allocution télévisée du président de
la fédération
décidément l'utile l'unité de la
yougoslavie est à l'épreuve
emmanuel vanier
l'agitation 70 ans yougoslavie après la
voïvodine la semaine dernière le
mouvement de protestation a atteint le
monténégro manifestations et hier et
aujourd'hui de plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui exige le départ des
dirigeants de la province
200 étudiants d'entamer une grève de la
faim pour protester contre les violences
policières
hier soir fait sans précédent depuis la
mort de tito le président de la
république raif dizdarevic s'est adressé
à la population dans une allocution
télévisée et radiodiffusée
le président demande au gouvernement des
mesures d'urgence pour mettre fin à
l'inflation et à la cherté de la vie
ils estiment les mécontentements
justifiée mais il met en garde les
manifestants tous les moyens
constitutionnels pourraient être mises
en oeuvre pour maintenir l'ordre
au moins 67 morts au sri lanka dont 45
saint gall et massacrés dans un petit
village du nord du pays
treize hommes 14 femmes et 18 enfants
égorgés pendant leur sommeil sans doute
par des séparatistes tamouls
il y a un an l'armée indienne avec de
nombreux soldats st gall et avait lancé
une offensive contre les séparatistes
tamouls qui aurait ainsi décidé de
marquer de façon brutale ce premier
anniversaire triple attentat la nuit
dernière au pays basque français pas de
victime mais des dégâts matériels
importants
les cibles des édifices publics à
bayonne saint-jean-de-luz et à ce parent
les bombes d engin rudimentaire une
bouteille de gaz avec un système de mise
à feu commandé par un réveil trois
attentats revendiqués cet après-midi par
l'organisation clandestine dissoute
iparretarrak depuis un an les
séparatistes basques avaient peu fait
parler d'eux en france il semble donc
que l'organisation ce soir restructurer
malgré l'arrestation de son chef présumé
philippe bidart en février dernier
revenons maintenant à la crise
algérienne et au discours télévisé du
président chadli le chef de l'état
algérien
après six jours de silence parle
toujours depuis donc maintenant plus de
vingt minutes
alors les grandes lignes de ce discours
jusqu'ici car ses rangs écoutez le
président chez nikko bull n'a pas tout à
fait fini de parler simplement il a
garanti d'abord avec visage fermé vivant
et tout visage grave surtout que le
peuple algérien se trouvait face à des
choix difficiles
il a expliqué que la situation les
causes de cette crise était à la fois
économique et lé fois démographique ça
on savait il a expliqué aussi aux jeunes
chaussures il a fait appel qu'il fallait
rester calme il a promis que le peuple
algérien aurait tâche prononcer bientôt
sur des réformes en profondeur qu'il
fallait réparer les choses
il a promis surtout que finalement il
pouvait rester au pouvoir parce que le
peuple algérien
je les fais confiance et qu'il pensait
que maintenant il fallait aller au bout
de son devoir
voilà ce qu'on peut dire maintenant
jusqu'à présent en tout cas alors tout
de suite allons rejoindre alger jacques
merino jacques j'espère que la ligne
téléphonique est bonne on ne peut pas
vous voir malheureusement on n'a pas de
liaison télévisée alors votre première
analyse à ce discours au début de ce
discours en tout cas
enfin le suivons le dire présent quasi
avec un groupe de jeunes algériens alors
tout de suite comme cela en un show et
son après visant à dissiper les trois
remarques et il m'en charger de faire
attention arrive tard six jours après le
début des émeutes
il aurait été tellement pas le plus tôt
pour sa vie vient de faire montre
l'image et donc personne avec qui
négocier alors que la troisième est
gagnant la marque est la plus importante
et la plus grave alors jacques une
question précise il semble que l'armée
si vous m'entendez toujours inspiré des
grincements sur la ligne l'armée semble
t'il est intervenu très brutalement cet
après midi à bab el oued et d'après
certaines rumeurs des unités l'armée
aurait tiré contre les soldats appelés
pour les empêcher de fraterniser avec
les manifestants est ce que est ce que
cet exode après ce que vous savez sur
place
avec les moyens ce que vous me dites
mais je ne suis pas ce que c'est petit
car depuis le début des mesures voix on
m'a dit que tu avais du mal à se faire
obéir à des spectacles sont souvent des
jeunes rappelé jacques merlino merci et
c'est vrai comme comme on pouvait le
craindre la ligne téléphonique était
parfois difficile et 7,7
réaction à chaud un peu à peu difficile
à entendre alors les réactions à paris
maintenant les réactions à radio beur
abdel aïssou mouloud salah bonsoir vous
avez donc suivi en direct vous continuez
d'écouter j'imagine le discours du
président chadli est ce qu'à votre avis
c'est un langage que les jeunes à alger
peuvent comprendre ce soir c'est
effectivement un grand discours mais
avec un manque de précision christine si
j'ai bien compris le président chadli a
promis de la forme au niveau des
institutions au niveau de la gestion de
ce pays et n'a pas été assez précis
si j'ai bien compris aussi c'est que le
peuple algérien en général à travers ces
événements dramatiques pose une question
énorme c'est la représentation sans
retour sa représentation dans ce pays
participer à la gestion des affaires de
ce pays
les cancans le président chadli annonce
des réformes politiques et même
éventuellement d'une réforme
constitutionnelle est ce que cela
voudrait dire la fin du parti unique
première question il faudrait qu'il
affûte il précisé
cette question là est ce que le parti
unique sera le seul parti qui sera
appelée à l'avenir à se maintenir
est ce qu'il y aura un attachement
visite des oppositions il arrive du
droit d'association est ce que le peuple
algérien aura pour la première fois les
moyens d'élire son président ou ses
représentants
je pense qu'à ce question n'a pas été
précis et je crois qu'il faut qu'il soit
un peu plus rigoureux pour que le peuple
algérien puisse peut-être retrouver sa
sérénité vis-à-vis de tous ces
événements traumatiques et qui puisse
ramener les âmes et dans les casernes
je crois que l'algérie n'a pas seulement
besoin de ce mood et d'huile elle a
besoin si d'oxygène il faut que un
peuple qui a vécu ces événements
puissent avoir des réponses très
précises
c'est à dire la liberté de s'associer
d'association d'expression d'être ne pas
paraître
alors au delà de l'analyse politique
donc que vous faites ainsi à chaud
est-ce que les accents trouvé par le
président est ce que ce sont langage son
vocabulaire son émotion éventuel est ce
que est ce qu'il y avait cela dans ce
site ce discours où est-ce qu'ils
étaient aussi froid qu'il en avait l'air
pour quelqu'un qui malheureusement ne
comprend pas la règle je suis persuadé
qu'on ne peut pas remettre en cause la
société du président monsieur chat du
président mais je suis persuadé aussi
que le sens suffira pas à calmer les
esprits actuellement alger il faudrait
des prêtres des réponses plus précises
et il faudrait que ça devienne très très
vite arrêter ce carnage arrêter cette
boucherie woodsen à merci donc le
président chadli continue de parler le
couvre-feu je vous le rappel doit être
rétablie alger ce soir à 22h en principe
alger donc où il ya eu encore une
trentaine de morts cet après-midi lors
d'affrontements entre les intégristes et
les forces de l'anp changeant de
registre et parle au cinéma aux états
unis qui fait des ravages et rapporte
des millions c'est un lapin il s'appelle
roger et ses aventures vont commencer
sur les écrans français à partir de
mercredi
il est né de l'image
a sion et aussi de la nostalgie de
spielberg et d'un réalisateur un peu fou
qui rêvait de mariée le cinéma le vrai
avec de vrais acteurs et le dessin animé
avec tous ces personnages qui ne nous
quitte plus depuis l'enfance résultat
une prouesse technique est un formidable
succès commercial michel pasquet ce sont
les techniciens de george lucas ce
qu'ils ont mis au point pendant cinq
mois les douches sans trucage du film
relief trois dimensions maquette
voitures recouvertes de velours noir
redessiner ensuite en laboratoire
marionnettiste cachés dans les décors et
un acteur bob hoskins qui joue seul face
aux accessoires les plus incongrues et
avec un lapin qui reste pour lui
invisible
le guen
car outre la perfection des effets
spéciaux roger rabbit permet d'admirer
toutes les stars du dessin animé les
anciennes mais aussi de nouvelles venues
comme la pulpeuse
jessica avait besoin de pain pour faire
le sale boulot non non non j'ai mon
arrivée vous vous trompez sur nos côtes
vous ne savez pas constitue d'être une
femme qui en officine ah oui
qui veut la peau de roger rabbit à
partir de mercredi sur vos écrans
les pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé demain à vincennes le 17 le 15
le 19 le vin le 11 le 7 le 10 et le 5
voilà à minuit vous avez rendez vous
avec henri sannier pour une nouvelle
formule de notre dernier journal demain
6h45 télématin invité des 4 vérités
le patron de l'année élu par le nouvel
économiste suspense merci d'avoir suivi
ce journal à demain 20 heures